[Music]
when President Crump needs South Korea's
new president when JM at their first
Washington summit in June 2017 the two
leaders will have a chance to forge a
personal bond that could strengthen the
us-rok Alliance against growing North
Korean threats but the meeting also
entails non-trivial risks president moon
favors a departure from the current
joint us-rok approach towards North
Korea and return instead to a sunshine
policy the more conciliatory engagement
oriented posture with which Seoul
experimented during the clinton and
george w bush administrations president
moon wishes to reverse or at least
suspend south korea's implementation of
bad missile defense he wishes to reopen
the ROK sponsored Kaesong Industrial
Complex in the north shut down by his
predecessor on suspicion was funneling
money to Kim jong-un's nuclear and
missile program also it seems
uncomfortable pressing North Korea on
its human rights violation last time
around sunshine policies called us-rok
relations to suffer and work for ria
profit will moon shine fare better stay
tuned to learn more about my take on
North Korea check the links in the
description below also let us know what
other topics you want a EEI scholars to
cover in 60 seconds